I have a crazy crazy clip for you this
relates to the entire culture of people
will be lazy from the right this is a
common thread from the right it's
arguably this particular clip one of the
most disconnected desperate attempts
from Fox News to make basic welfare and
social good programs look bad because
they'll just make everybody lazy and the
right has been pushing this narrative
for a really long time it arguably dates
all the way back to Ronald Reagan's
totally bogus story about I believe it
was the Cadillac driving welfare queen
but the common examples are if you give
people in employment benefit
unemployment benefits you are
incentivizing not working so people will
not work if people get a basic income
then nobody will work if you disconnect
health insurance from employment people
won't want to work since they won't need
to work in order to keep their health
insurance anymore if you give people
food stamps they won't work because
they'll be upset or whatever right so
that these are pretty transparently
bogus arguments which gets us to Fox
News's John Scott just a couple of days
ago now if you're not familiar with Fox
News is John Scott he's one of the most
boneheaded and really one of the most
obviously clueless on policy Fox News
Talking Heads he came up with something
that is brilliant in its insanity this
was a discussion that they had about
Donald Trump cutting some of these
Obamacare subsidies for low-income
people and I told you the details of
that earlier this week and in that
conversation John Scott suggested you
know if everybody just gets gets free
care why would anyone even try to stay
healthy
these are 17 seconds of unbelievable
total utter garbage and I'm presenting
them to you here take a look at this
what's the motivation if these are the
you know the the poorest Americans who
are getting their co-pays and things
like that covered what's the motivation
for them to try to live a healthier
lifestyle I mean if it doesn't cost them
anything to go to the doctor what's the
motivation
if healthcare is covered what would
motivate people to be healthy oh I don't
know maybe the human desire to remain
alive can you imagine this level of
disconnected depraved thinking we talk
about nature versus nurture what
characteristics are learned versus what
characteristics are instinctual or
ingrained and there's lots of debate
about many of those but there's one that
is not controversial which is the human
instinct to survive and John Scott is
framing this as if you know if people
know that no matter what they do whether
they live a sedentary lifestyle or
remain active whether they eat
unhealthily or they eat healthily no
matter what they are going to not have
to pay co-payments so people are all of
a sudden going to have no incentive
whatsoever to live a healthy life can
you imagine
oh I no longer have to pay twenty five
bucks to go and be seen by my doctor
well I'm gonna start binging on the most
addictive drugs never exercising and
eating myself to morbid obesity because
I no longer have an incentive to be
healthy it implies that the only
incentive to remain healthy is to avoid
the costs associated with obtaining
health care this is out of this world
total rock-bottom Fox News insanity but
I I wouldn't be just playing these
seventeen seconds of video if the only
reason were to make fun of John Scott
and that's a really good reason but it's
not the only reason that I'm doing this
there's this reminder in the background
of an incorrect talking point around
so-called free health care which of
course I call it so-called
it's not really free right I mean you
pay for it through taxes that that's not
really something that is hidden by
advocates of single-payer health care or
Medicare for all there's this idea that
as soon as people don't have to pay for
co-payments or premiums for health
insurance they will start overusing
health insurance like it's some kind of
entertainment right
it's a total and utter myth the idea
that as soon as you have no co-pays
you're going to start looking for
unnecessary medical procedures as soon
as you can because you don't have to pay
for them is absolutely ridiculous it's
not borne out by any research that has
been done and the truth is if all of a
sudden people didn't have to pay
co-payments for health insurance they'd
probably get care earlier at the first
signs of some conditions which is
significantly cheaper for the system
than letting conditions worsen and then
needing treatment of an acute problem
people now tend to want to avoid their
25 or 50 dollar copay or more depending
on what insurance you have until a
condition is serious because the
rationale is hey if I've got to pay a
copay and I'm probably okay if this is
probably just a virus that will go away
on its own that is a disincentive to get
treatment earlier so this john scott
clip is completely and totally whacked
out but it actually does relate to a
common talking point about single-payer
or medicare for all that is important to
debunk and meanwhile i guess we also
have to tell john scott that there is
this thing called the human desire to
live that most animals actually share
with us which sort of creates an
incentive to not eat yourself into total
morbid obesity or to start binging on
the most destructive of addictive drugs